Tucker is a rock star right Tucker is
one of the people that you actually work
with and you know that he believes what
he's saying that he's committed to
principle that if he makes a mistake and
gets something wrong he's going to say
it which is so incredibly rare in media
Tucker is going to be a rock star no
matter what he does uh I think he's
going to go off and do something on his
own he may start a company of his own he
will get his voice and his content and
his message out to people so I think
people could rest assured that he's not
going away anytime soon I think his
video that now I think has almost 80
million uh reach I think expressed that
he's also laughing about these leaks I
mean this is very predictable when you
work in corporate media they very
obviously fired him they very obviously
silenced him over at Fox he was very
clearly having editorial conflict with
senior leadership and just wasn't going
to sit down and shut up